[Musica]
[Applauso]
qui
berruti e bentornati meter stories dove
ogni volta dovremo vivere una strana
avventura assieme ma questa volta cosa
ci faceva quel gorilla enorme nel mio
giardino
forse stava cercando qualcosa da
mangiare oppure semplicemente voleva
darmi fastidio come tutti gli altri
io dovrò comunque cercare gli
ingredienti slime in giardino in casa
non so dove sono nascosti ma ho un'idea
per sti spec suo punto debole
almeno credo e spero che funzioni ma
andiamo andiamo dobbiamo andare in
cucina ecco a ragazzi il cestino della
frutta prendo tutte le banane che ci
sono e spero che cascheranno la mia
trappola
così mi potrà lasciare in pace a casa
mia secondo voi funzionerà queste
basteranno
ci sono tantissime e mi sono dimenticato
di dirvi se non mi seguite ancora su
instagram andate a seguirmi il nome
anita stories se volete andate a
seguirmi anche su tik tok e ora andiamo
a cercare il nuovo disturbatore e
tiriamo di qualche banana in te perche i
ragazzi sono prontissima ho già due
banali in tasca e una la tengo pronta al
lancio non posso prenderne un'altra
perché nella camera nella mano la camera
non nella camera o la mano iniziamo ad
andare in giardino e vediamo se troviamo
qualche ingrediente
sì stiamo bene attenti
vediamo se c'è qualcosa con un giardino
mi sembra di vedere qualcosa qui berlino
che c'è un aiuto pronti con la banana e
puro come l'ha subito che i danni da
pamela come faccio a me lo fate votare
un'altra guadagna
[Musica]
ragazzi siamo riusciti a prendere la
colla il problema è che merlino ha
rubato una delle mie banane ora mi
rimane solo una banana ma ricarichiamo
abbiamo ancora tre banane 4 più quella
di berlino mano ma la ridarà mai fatto
bene a mita è pronta a la salle
torniamo subito e cerchiamo gli altri
ingredienti
[Musica]
stiamo bene attenti a dove sarà il
gorilla lo vedo vediamo se c'è qualche
ingrediente però c'è berlino dal grillo
guardate il carrello una ciotola tipo di
strada in qualche modo
perché sta mangiando la banana con la
ciotola e la spatola
ehi guarda un po che cosa qua
vai a prenderla a prenderli che viviamo
perché così scadente nella mia trappola
merito cosa hai fatto questa barare bene
a vita ha avuto successo perché questa
volta ho preso la ciotola e la scatola
ora mi manca solo la soluzione per lenti
il bicarbonato devo pensare a nuove
tecniche per distrarlo io ho lanciato la
banale da nostra parte ed è andato a
prenderlo ma si sarà accorto che gli ho
rubato qualcosina si sta votando per
mangiare la banana
quindi ora devo stare super attenta
anche perché non solo 1 2 e 3 banale
avete visto berlino come ha disintegrato
e quella banana ma è normale marino
disintegra qualsiasi cosa renda
carlo martino
[Musica]
provate a ri la banana in scambio vieni
da me
eviterete un altro grazie ciao sono
riuscita a recuperare anche il
bicarbonato l'unico problema è che ora
mi rimane solo una banana perché il
gorilla voleva due banane per il
bicarbonato non una speriamo di riuscire
a recuperare anche la soluzione per
lenti con solo una banana che i ragazzi
facciamo con la mia unica parola ancora
giù avrà una soluzione equa clienti
ha messo la soluzione perché vogliamo
scambiare mutamenti una banana tin.it su
questa tdt anche berlino ei dovuti
giardino con la lite svecchiati colista
vince scappare ciao berlino
poiché i ragazzi più recuperato l'ultimo
ingrediente la soluzione per lenti e ora
il grilli dalla finestra che mi guarda
guarda te sta aspettando che i credi lo
slime non lo so ma sbrighiamoci iniziamo
dal col bellissimo questa colla oro
glitterato capello è pieno di click
ora il carbonato e soluzioni per lenti
mescoliamo tutto la tata tata cercate un
po
eccolo qua è pronto e bellissimo così
dorato con te ti l'iter
ma vediamo se ha funzionato anche questa
volta s l'intruso se n'è andato vediamo
[Musica]
ha funzionato abbiamo vinto la soul ed
ho anche questa volta tutto grazie ai
superpoteri di banalità le sue banane mi
raccomando lasciate un bel mi piace se
volete vedere altre challenge trovo agli
ingredienti slime se questo mi
terrorizza i 30 mila mi piace ci sarà
un'altra solent trova gli ingredienti
slime è ora vi lascio qui 4 caselline
sacrificare per vedere i nostri altri
video cliccate su quella che preferite e
buona visione
[Musica]